good afternoon everybody it's absolutely
wonderful to be here at Le VC and I want
to congratulate everybody here in this
building almost all the staff for what
you do to make these incredible machines
with their lovely traditional contours
burly bulging faintly reminiscent of a
black bowler hat but underneath the
familiar silhouette there is now
technology so advanced that this machine
can take you silently with from Oxbridge
to Upminster I think I'm right
insane silently fraught switch routers
with barely a puff of co2 zero co2 so
that these taxis are beginning to cut
thousands of tons a year from London's
carbon emissions I think 10,000 tonnes
per year and they're not only popular
with the traveling public but popular
with taxi drivers themselves and believe
me there are pretty demanding clients
that I happen to remember so in its
ambition and in its daring I hope you
will not mind you know given I identify
this machine as a symbol of the type of
politics that I believe in my type of
conservative politics what I stand for
and the approach that I want to take and
what we as a government have to offer
this country in just a few weeks time
because I believe the job of politicians
is to drive change and I was you know
bubbly this I was the Midwife of this
taxi I was one I was or one of the
midwives well I'm going to come to our
investment in midwives later on it's
gonna be very considerable but I
remember I remember going to see
chairman Li in Beijing in 2008 and I had
my first meeting with him in one of
several meetings and he said then that
he wanted to buy the company that made
the London taxis some of you may
remember this and I said fantastic let's
make them in Britain because I want to
be pure of that and chairman Li said yes
he would and then I chanced my arm
because I was determined to tackle
air pollution in London I said fantastic
let's make them electric zero carbon and
chairman Lee said he would see what he
could do and he said we will research it
and I have to tell you that at that time
there were plenty of cynics not least
some of the other manufacturers who said
that diesel was the only way to go and
they said they wouldn't be enough
sockets for the plugs and that the
battery would be so heavy that the taxi
wouldn't move well I don't know where
they are now but I hope that they are
eating their words
ladies and gentlemen because you here at
Le VC are making thousands of these
wonderful machines here in the West
Midlands home of the first Industrial
Revolution we are seeing a new
Industrial Revolution a green Industrial
Revolution contain creating thousands of
environmentally sustainable technologies
and thousands of jobs a glorious
rebuttal to the skeptics who said it
couldn't be done and in our world
leading technologies from batteries to
bioscience the Britain of 2019 is in
many ways a crushing rejoinder to the
post-war pessimism of so many in the
British establishment who then believed
that this country was fated to decline
because today the UK boasts more Nobel
Prize winners than any country except
the US we dominate the global pop music
charts we even dominate I saw the market
in Hollywood superheroes with British
actors playing both Spider Man and
Superman under this government we have
an economy
I'm gonna take I'm gonna take credit for
under this under this government we have
an economy that has grown solidly for
nine years twenty percent bigger than it
was well in 2010 and yesterday it was an
answer the rate of unemployment has
fallen to a low not seen since 1974 but
you know there's still something
frustrating for me about this recitation
of our country's triumphs because it is
a story of an economy that is still not
achieving what it could of a country
like a cup winning racehorse trying to
run on three legs with so much more
potential waiting to be unleashed and
that is why it is the mission of this
one nation Conservative government to
unite and to level up across the whole
of the UK ensuring one nation observe
ensuring that everyone has safer streets
with 20,000 more police lifting up
funding for every school in the country
massive investments in health so that
you don't have to wait to see your GP
providing vastly better infrastructure
investing in skills that drive up
productivity and drive up wages biggest
ever increase in the living wage we've
announced 210 pounds fifty so cutting
the costs of living across the country
and that is the one nation program on
which this government is embarked and
yet my friends here in rugby oh by the
way pace I pay tribute mark palsy who's
the the local MP and he would want me to
say that my friends my friends we are it
does a fantastic job
we are blocked we are stymied for the
last three months we have a parliament
where there is no majority since I've
been in office no majority to take
forwards those people's priorities a
paralyzed Parliament that refuses time
and again to honor the mandate of the
people and to live to deliver brexit
and that is why we need this election
now that's why we need we've got
absolutely no choice
we must get brexit done because we're
Democrats and there are millions who
want to get brexit done because they
voted leave and they believe that the EU
has become something very different from
what it was when we signed up in its
with the Common Market in 1975 with the
first referendum and then of course
there are huge numbers who may have
voted remain but who just want to
respect the result of the referendum and
after three and a half years they think
it's time for the wrangling to end and I
don't know about you but I'm with them
aren't you yes we have to get we have to
get brexit done because it's the best
thing for our politics and for our
psychological health we have to get
brexit done because it's also the best
thing for the economy the uncertainty
has become almost unbearable people
can't make decisions they're hanging
fire waiting to hire new staff waiting
to buy new property the UK attracts huge
quantities of foreign direct investment
92 billion last year more than any other
country in in Europe but right now there
is a pent up tidal wave of new
investment tens of billions that more
that could come to this country in the
next few months from people who see that
we have the right timezone the right
language great universities fantastic
skills and they're just waiting to
greenlight their plans and if we could
get brexit done we could end their
uncertainty and let me make no bones
about it one of the most important
reasons for voting conservative and to
help us to get a working majority is
that we can get brexit done now we have
a deal we have a great deal it's ready
to go just add water stir stir in pot
it's there the skeptics the skeptics
said it couldn't be done and they were
totally wrong this deal allows us to
maximize all the opportunities of brexit
Freeport's to free trade deals from
cutting v80 on tampons to banning the
cruel the cruel export of live animals
we can take back control of our money
our borders are our laws we can take
back control of our immigration system
and decide democratically who gets to
come here for the good of the UK economy
and it gives business complete stability
and certainty as we make the transition
in January and come out and the best
thing as I say is that it's done it's
complete it's ready to go it's the it's
the Blue Peter deal here's one I made
earlier all we've all we need all we
need is a working majority all we need
is a working majority in parliament to
make Parliament work just nine more
seats just nine more seats a week and
deliver brexit in January and get
Parliament working for you and unleash
the potential of the whole country
and get on with our agenda the only
thing that held up that deal in
Parliament you may remember and tripped
us up at the final hurdle was yes I'm
afraid to say it Jeremy Corbyn and the
Labour Party and what exactly does
Corbin what would he do in the Corbin
Sturgeon coalition that would actually
that I think his only means of forming a
government in this country his only path
to power well if only we knew what he
would do the only hard crouton of fact
in the great minestrone of muddle that
constitutes Labour's brexit policy is
that he wants more delay turning 2020
into a year of two referendums as Nicola
Sturgeon confirmed today one on Scotland
on which Corbin's position is veiled in
mystery
does he want to protect the Union or
would he join Nicola Sturgeon in trying
to break up the most successful
political partnership over the last 300
years who knows as for his position on
the EU it's positively mind-boggling he
wants to negotiate a new deal at least
he wants another three months to
negotiate a new deal then
he wants to spend a further six months
asking the public to vote on his deal in
yet another toxic referendum campaign
and we don't even know what his own
position will be will he campaign
against the New Deal that he hopes to
secure is he for leave is he for remain
or is he like Schrodinger's cat capable
occupying two contradictory positions at
once one thing is is clear the sturgeon
korban alliance would consign this
country to months if not years or giver
delay discord division when every month
of pointless delay insisted on by Corman
by the way it's costing this country a
billion pounds for nothing just to stay
in right now I think what we could spend
that billion pounds on my friends every
month that's a net contribution by the
way but a billion pounds per month
that's almost twenty thousand police
officers a billion pounds we need to get
brexit done so we can spend that money
on our priorities in the uncertainty and
get on with our program of uniting and
leveling up across the whole of the UK
because if the potential of this country
is enormous then so frankly is the
injustice some regions are fifty percent
less productive than London there's some
parts of the country where people's
lives are a decade shorter than in other
parts occasional outcomes can be vastly
different imagine if every child had the
same start the same encouragement think
of all the untapped talent in this
country and yet the solutions to that
inequality are within our grasp our
ambition is to unlock the whole nation's
potential through infrastructure better
infrastructure better education and
technology not just to close the
opportunity gap
between rich and poor but also between
the regions of this country were so
ambitious we believe we can close both
gaps at once not by decapitating the
tall poppies but by spreading equality
of opportunity and there are some things
that I think everybody should have as a
matter of right freedom to walk the
streets without fear of crime we need to
stop our kids getting sucked into the
county lines drugs gangs Benway we need
safer streets and proper punishment and
that means a police government that
funds the police and that backs the
police and that's why we've already
begun not just by the investing in the
twenty thousand officers but also
backing them up with proper powers to do
stop and search tougher sentences for
serious sexual and violent crimes of
course the best way to stop kids getting
caught up in crime is to give every
child in this country an excellent
education and that is why we are
spitting four pupil funding so that each
pupil gets a minimum of four thousand
pounds in primary school a minimum of
five thousand pounds in secondary
schools we're putting about 780 million
more into special educational needs
schools and we're spending 2 billion
pounds in rebuilding our further
education colleges because they are a
vital part of our educational system is
not just about university it's about
giving kids across our country the
skills that we need and as we leave the
EU we will insist that all big public
sector projects must hire British
apprentices so that they can learn new
skills on the job and at the same time
as we improve education we are ensuring
that people are able to exploit the
opportunities that are available to them
literally to find the work the great
jobs are high skilled jobs conveniently
and affordably and the only way to do
that is to invest in superb transport
communications and that's why this
government is embarking on an
infrastructure revolution and yes
means some some very big projects I've
done loads them in London fantastic new
electrified rail but it also means now
investing in the simple improvements to
their lives that people have been
craving modernizing roads and junctions
that have become bottlenecks and source
is a massive local frustration and
economic inefficiency it's about better
bus services which can make all the
difference to people's lives and
prospects in towns villages and rural
communities better cycle ways I'm glad
to see some nodding their cycle ways not
always popular with the taxi drivers in
my experience but better that's what we
need better cycle ways across the across
the country and we want I want every
home every business in the country to
have the confidence and convenience that
comes with gigabit broadband 5g and 6g
mobile telephony and that is how to
unite the country to bring us together
infrastructure education technology and
to raise productivity that is how to
create a platform for growth that's what
the role of government is and if you
create that platform for growth then the
market will respond in two vital ways if
you have good transport and safe
environment good schools then suddenly
the market will find that it can build
thousands more homes superb affordable
homes on brownfield sites giving young
people the chance to have the keys to
their own property which every survey
continues to show is one of our most
fundamental instincts and if we're
helping we will help with a big
expansion of part by part rent schemes
to help people get onto the housing
ladder and if you have safe
neighborhoods decent housing a skilled
workforce good transport links then what
else happens you get business investment
you get confidence and you get jobs and
that's why you need a government that
believes in business that understands
wealth creation and the need to support
family visits and cuts
and cut business rate sir there have
been 1.4 million businesses created in
this country since 2010 1.4 million
Napoleon said that we were a nation of
shopkeepers and I think that so that's
an insult that we can take isn't it he
was right by the way there'd be more
businesses created in this country since
2010 than by France and Germany combined
I'm proud to say and that is the that is
the balance and the symmetry at the
heart of our one nation conservatism
between fantastic public services
building the platform for growth and a
strong dynamic market economy and what I
say when people get up at the crack of
dawn to get their business ready where
people take out a mortgage for a new
venture where people have the guts to
put a new product on the market we don't
sneer we cheer for them and to make sure
that the businesses of this country can
continue to innovate we're announcing
today I'm announcing that this
government if we reelect it will not
only invest more to support electric
vehicle technology yes we will double
funding for research and development to
18 billion pounds in the next parliament
the biggest ever increase in support for
R&D and we proudly back businesses
across this country because they are
creating the wealth that actually pays
for the NHS and everything else and they
are helping to create the jobs and I'm
afraid that is the key difference
between us a one nation Tory government
and the Labour Party under Jeremy Corbyn
it's not just that labour would be an
economic disaster for this country
because they would delay delay brexit
yet again they would simultaneously
wreck this economy with a 1.2 trillion
pound spending splurge they will be
instantly rejected by the markets that
would massively increase not just this
country's debt but also the cost of this
country's debt by taking out a mortgage
to pay for your groceries
and they would make it impossible to
make future sensible investments that
this country needs in the NHS and other
great public services and to pay for it
they would put up taxes on every
household in the country to the tune of
two thousand four hundred pounds a year
in fact they were some selves so worried
about a run on the pound that John
MacDonald the Shadow Chancellor it has
already said that he's actually going to
impose exchange controls on this country
again can you imagine the only countries
that have exchange controls these days
are places like Angola Zimbabwe and
Venezuela you guessed it well do we want
to have our economy run out of the
PlayBook of Bolivarian revolutionary
socialism I don't think so we can't let
it happen but that is the the choice of
this election you can come with us and
have a government that backs our armed
forces as a path for good around the
world or you can have Jeremy Corbyn who
said but on the whole he wants to to
scrap them you can come with us we
support the police in fighting knife
crime they say stop and search is
inappropriate and oppressive we want
higher wages and a raising as I say that
the living wage by the biggest ever
increase Corbin onyx Corbin ah mcc's
means higher taxes for everyone we know
that the only way we can make our huge
investments in the NHS is if we also
have a strong and dynamic market economy
in and John McDonald has literally said
that he wants to ferment the overthrow
of capitalism that is his mission
so he says we stand up for the people of
this country when other nations threaten
us with harm and it was quite incredible
when Russia ordered the Salisbury
poisonings Corbin seemed actually to to
take the side of of Moscow above all we
will get brexit done and unleash the
potential of the whole country they want
dither and delay deadlock and division
doubt and despair all which
go with another referendum and I say to
you all let's give that madness amiss I
want you to imagine what this country
could be like in just 10 years as a
result of the decisions we are taking
now and have taken over the last three
months I want you to look forward to a
Britain where the streets are safer
where the air is cleaner well we have
built 40 new hospitals as a direct
result of the program on which we've
just embarked the decisions we've taken
it Britain where the ten-year-olds of
tomorrow have benefited from the funding
for literacy and numeracy that were
unleashing today an opportunity is being
spread across the whole country and
we're in 10 years time scientists are
starting to reap the huge rewards from
our plans to double funding for research
and businesses as well from space to
artificial intelligence to a Giga
factory for batteries that we're going
to build in the next three years
a Britain where we are uniting and
leveling up across the country where
great new infrastructure is helping to
rebalance the economy where we are
delivering northern powerhouse rail and
a metro style system for the whole of
the West Midlands our Britain we're left
behind towns have recovered their
vibrancy and commercial life with shops
and businesses made possible by a better
transport and fantastic broadband and
with responsible local politicians who
know how to champion their communities
and to build thousands of superb new
homes on brownfield sites and plant
millions of trees not just because
they're beautiful but because they will
help us in dealing with flooding and
with climate change I want you to
imagine a Britain whose regions
experienced a renaissance at the same
time as our incomparable capital city
lengthens its lead as the financial
business tech artistic cultural academic
capital of Europe if not the world and
in 10 years time
I confidently prophesied that we will
all be citizens of a proud strong and
whole United Kingdom more United than
ever flying that red white and blue flag
that represents the best of our values
from democracy to the rule of law from
free trade to free speech to the freedom
to love whomsoever you choose from
tackling climate change to protecting
the wildlife of the world from the
tragedy of habitat loss and extinction
and a Britain that is able to lead the
world as we do in tackling climate
change and to reduce our co2 to net zero
by 2050 not because we hate capitalism
not just by gluing ourselves to the tops
of tube trains or whatever important
though that may be to make a point
not because you want to destroy market
economics but because it is precisely
through the brilliance of companies like
this one that we can make the technical
breakthroughs that enable us to cut co2
and go for carbon neutral by 2050 and of
course that helped us to pay for great
public services and to create wonderful
high-skilled jobs and that is the vision
that we are offering to make this
country the greatest place to live to
breathe to be to raise kids to start a
business the greatest place on earth
great space on earth not necessarily the
most powerful the greatest place on
earth and I propose that we get on with
that project now don't you let's not
hang around I don't want to waste 2020
with two more soul-destroying
referendums I want next year to be an
exciting year and a productive year a
year of prosperity and growth a year
that it's about the people of this
country and not about it's politicians
and I ask you finally do you want to
wake up on Friday the 13th
and find a nightmare in Downing Street
and nightmare on Downing Street a korben
korben sturgeon Technicolor coalition of
chaos is that what you want no it
certainly isn't it certainly is I think
it'd be disaster for this country so
let's let's thank you all for your time
let's go forward with sensible moderate
one nation but tax-cutting conservative
government and take this country
forwards over the next ten years thank
you all very much your kind attention
yourself